hey guys so this is Ryan he doesn't get
to talk because he didn't read The Fault
in Our Stars book okay and I did I love
John Green he's amazing
he'll pcs this and like it says
something to me he's author of the book
for anyone who doesn't know that I'm
really excited about this trailer do you
know anything about it no I do know it's
called The Fault in Our Stars yes and
that's a quote from Shakespeare another
way oh it is yeah oh wow um fascinating
I'll give you a little synopsis
basically it's about a girl with cancer
and her being like I hate cancer and
it's basically like it breaks down all
the cliches it's like yeah I mean I'm
strong whatever I [ __ ] you that's what
she's like in the book and it's great
and then she meets a boy and it's not
all like gushy and cheesy it's actually
pretty realistic in my opinion of how I
would react if I had cancer and there's
not boy it was just like a ho thing out
so did they fall in love
yeah oh and then she dies you don't know
that I read the book she probably dies
she has cancer where's the cancer um the
cancers in her lungs but what you also
find out in the book is that you used to
have cancer his legs that he you said
cancer yeah I mean what walks of braces
and stuff oh so they try to give you
hope that she's gonna survive but she
doesn't and it's his heartbreaking tale
it's a heartbreaking tale but the great
part about the book is that is that it
focuses so much on like her being like
I'm gonna die she tells everyone she's a
grenade you know she's gonna die soon
and let's watch it I could catch a
grenade for you
[Music]
babylonians head off to divergence
remind me of us confident Wow I wish I
could be just like that
[Music]
talks about you all the time one day I'm
gonna blow up one before I read the book
I thought she was talking about
everything at my right hot hey that guys
in True Blood
you don't get to choose if you get hurt
in this world but you do have a say in
who hurts you I'm in love with you hazel
grace and I know that love is just a
shout into the void and that oblivion is
inevitable I like this guy
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
answer sex
you angry so angry you need a break
[Music]
give me forever within the numbered days
I can't tell you how they died
[Applause]
[Music]
because nd feel about it I like it I
like it that's right yeah that's really
good actually
look she's a great actress like she's
amazing
who's that guy he's confident well he's
an unknown they wanted someone he wasn't
mm-hmm and all the girls would just
focus on that and not the actual story
it looks normal enough he knows that too
honky-tonk I'm gonna cry so hard in this
movie like I cried reading the book I
was like [ __ ] you John Green's I love
you do like why did you do that to me
and I'll be there to comfort you Sally
[Music]
can't say one nice thing to this girl
without her singing would you want to
see it with me yeah of course I'll go
with you Sally because I'm probably
gonna see it like the midnight showing
it so excited I am for all you who
haven't read the book you should because
it's really touching and I think it'll
make a little bit on how you live your
life yeah not gonna be all cheesy
minister and John Green please I almost
like carved your face on a pumpkin for
as a joke but can you like follow me on
tumblr or something or like send me a
message or something because you're
awesome
I watched Mental Floss I watched Mental
Floss like all the time and you're great
in it yeah in Sasha Grey that's porn
star in the world if you're out there
please follow me on Twitter the real
ride right oh my god I tell you logan
lerman 'he's friends band is following
me on Twitter about crap I mean I'm a
bride no I'm not that crazy not crazy
enough to cry but crazy enough to
[ __ ] pass but if you're new to the
channel oh yeah I'm subscribed no big
deal just click this button it clear
water down my butt
yeah her button rear button right here
soft hands
I barely grazes Wow my boyfriend's like
you just softened I'm like dude you tell
me is like all the time it's never gonna
Jam you thank you if I'm not soft I'm
not a girl ouch there are some girls
with skin diseases I dated a girl once
who had a condition where she had
permanent dry skin for the rest of her
life like everywhere yeah that's really
bad sorry no I just look Sally it's okay
sorry your ear you just weren't thinking
what can I say to tell her I had really
bad bladder problems what to make the
person feel better if they had dry skin
I have issues when I first ejaculated I
thought it was milk love how you slowly
reveal their sexual sides it's time it's
time before the battery dies I gotta
give some shoutouts I need to start
charging this battery keeps happening I
get a little bit impatient when my
camera's gonna die I feel like you were
like oh I rhymed and then yeah caught up
in the fact that you ride not able to
come walk to Brody studios to I think
yeah apparently this is the same Wow
good for you man you want a shout-out I
think we have a YouTube channel that
you're running to check his [ __ ] out
it's good [ __ ] his [ __ ] is like it's
like it's like good fiber to the same
dive good job buddy keep making videos
we're there with you all the way son